do you find that Mr Depp has proven all
the elements of defamation answer yes
the six-week defamation trial brought
both exes to the stand where they made
claims of abuse God did you just hit me
never did I myself reach the point of um
striking miss her I thought this is how
I die he's gonna kill me now that's me
in the emergency room the trial was set
into motion by this 2018 Washington Post
op-ed where Amber described herself as a
public figure representing domestic
abuse Johnny argued it caused him to
lose millions in movie deals when did
you first learn that Disney was not
going to recast you in the Pirates
franchise
two or three days after
this op-ed appeared Captain Jack Sparrow
was a character that I had built from
the ground up
I know that but herd took a hit too I
got dropped from campaign I'd shot I
fought to keep my job in the biggest
movie opportunity I had it was Justice
League it later became Aquaman it was it
was a global spectacle that gave fans
new insight into their toxic 15-month
marriage Johnny even claimed Amber left
him a parting gift after one of their
blowouts and on
my side of the bed
um
was human fecal matter I don't think
that's funny period that's disgusting
that did not come from a dog
I just didn't as the jury came to its
decision viewers came to theirs even
celebrities were caught up in the case
she's out of her mind like a crazy
actress Johnny Depp is a huge narcissist
I don't know how anybody wins in that
case I really don't I was on the edge of
the couch in sync star Lance Bass
reenacted herd's testimony I was just
sitting there on this carpet looking at
the dirty carpet wondering how I wound
up on this carpet but the actual
courtroom had just as much star power
with the battling X's roping in their
famous friends this is a message Paul
Bettany his drug buddy early on in their
relationship when he says let's burn
Amber let's drown her before we burn her
I once gave Marilyn Manson a pill so
that he would
stop talking so much
Amber's alleged Affairs went on the
record he hated James Franco and was
already accusing me of secretly having a
thing with him in my past do you know
whether or not
um misheard ever had a relationship with
Mr Elon Musk yes an admission from their
one-time talent agent Christian Carino
Lady Gaga's ex-fiancee she says I hate
that yet again a man lets me fall on the
spikes by myself
if you don't like being in the Press
about your personal life then
don't date people that are famous and
the most famous exes of them all Kate
Moss did Mr Depp during the course of
your relationship did he ever push you
down any stairs
no he never pushed me kicked me
all through me town and he says
the trial also turned many of Depp and
herd's acquaintances into overnight
Stars One in particular the former
doorman of their Penthouse Alejandro
Romero he gave a pre-recorded testimony
while vaping and driving yes yes I'm not
gonna say no Depp cracked up and the
judge was shocked that was a first I'm
sorry and how about this former TMZ
employee who took the stand on Depp's
behalf to explain how the Tabloid got a
hold of this video of Depp kicking and
smashing cabinets in his kitchen here's
what happened when herd's team got their
chance for questioning this gets you
your 15 minutes of fame objection your
honor argumentative I'm not seeking any
15 minutes here you're welcome to
speculate I could say the same thing by
taking Amber Heard as a client for you a
little argumentative don't you think oh
hardly and check out the reaction of
this guy behind herd's lawyer then there
are the memeable moments like Depp's
gummy bear stash and his Doodles the
clip of his artwork has gotten nearly 10
million views on Tick Tock I didn't want
to fail
ultimately Deb came out on top Amber
owes him more than 10 million bucks
while she was awarded 2 million dollars
to my dying day we'll stand by every
word of my testimony in the closing
arguments the depth lawyer said called
your testimony the performance of a
lifetime says the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
I'm the performer
but it's not over yet both parties are
appealing the verdicts A source told ET
in November bird is keeping a low
profile in Europe while raising her
one-year-old daughter and Depp just
ended his tour with friend Jeff Beck
[Music]